todo lo que hemos trabajado hasta ahora
tiene que ver con coordenadas
cartesianas tal vez tú no las conozcas
por ese nombre o yo no las había llamado
así hasta ahora pero qué son las
coordenadas cartesianas bueno para eso
voy a dibujar primero los ejes aquí está
el eje vertical aquí está el horizontal
las coordenadas cartesianas se pueden
trabajar para muchas dimensiones pero
normalmente trabajamos solo en dos y si
quiero especificar un punto en el
espacio bidimensional solo debo de
decirte que tanto se aleja en el eje
horizontal y que tanto se aleja en el
eje vertical por ejemplo si quiero dar
las coordenadas cartesianas de este
punto puedo decir para llegar a ese
punto tengo que moverme tres en el eje
horizontal eso es un 3 y después moverme
4 hacia arriba 1 2 3 4 en el vertical
por convención a este le llamamos x ya
esté la calle y también por convención a
esto le llamamos 3
4 decimos la primera coordenada es que
tanto me alejo en la dirección
horizontal y la segunda que tanto me
alejo arriba abajo en la vertical lo
podemos ver como que me moví 3 a la
derecha y después 4 para arriba o que me
moví 4 para arriba y 3 a la derecha y
esta es sólo una forma de especificar un
punto en dos dimensiones pero existen
otras como por ejemplo podemos decir que
tanto nos alejaremos y la dirección en
que lo haremos como en la vida real
apunta en esta dirección y aléjate esta
distancia en esta dirección
aléjate hasta acá y dará el mismo punto
y como determinaremos la dirección es
decir llamarle al eje x 0 grados hablar
en grados tiene sentido y también
conoces los radiales y podrías convertir
los grados en radiales así que esté 0 y
hay un ángulo entonces diremos que aquí
hay un ángulo el ángulo theta
y sólo tendrías que apuntar en esa
dirección con esta dirección y caminar
ciegamente r unidades después de r
unidades y llegarías al mismo punto y
así como especificamos en coordenadas
cartesianas al punto x ahora podríamos
identificarlo a ver vamos a pensar cómo
le hacemos y déjame escribirlo en
magenta como r coma theta que en esencia
dice camino r unidades en la dirección
theta pero vamos a descifrar esto porque
parece realmente abstracto y vamos a
utilizar la trigonometría y el teorema
de pitágoras podemos descubrir quiénes
son rt está claro aquí el más fácil será
r porque este es un triángulo rectángulo
si un triángulo rectángulo y esta
distancia es 3
y esta de acá es 4 este ángulo es recto
y quien es r pues el teorema de
pitágoras nos dice que 3 al cuadrado más
4 al cuadrado será r al cuadrado o sea
tenemos 3 al cuadrado más 4 al cuadrado
que es igual a r al cuadrado 916 es
igual a erre cuadrada 25 es igual a de
re cuadrada en este caso no vamos a
considerar la solución negativa y r es
igual a 5 ya sabemos que erre valen 5 y
cómo sabremos theta y qué es lo que
tenemos aquí bueno queremos saber el
valor de teta y que conocemos bueno
tenemos el lado opuesto esto tiene que
ver con soca tohá voy a escribir aquí
soca todas si no te suena familiar
habría que revisar el vídeo de
trigonometría básica tenemos el lado
opuesto a teta que tiene un valor de 4 y
el adyacente que tiene un valor de 3
cuál es la función trigonométricas que
involucra al opuesto y el adyacente
tohá que es opuesto y adyacente así que
la tangente de teta es igual al opuesto
que es la coordenada y que tiene un
valor de 4 dividido entre la coordenada
x que tiene un valor de 3
entonces la tangente de teta es 4
tercios y para evaluar esto vamos a
tomar la función inversa de la tangente
en ambos lados y esto es lo mismo claro
dependiendo del tipo de calculadora que
estés utilizando existen varias formas
de escribirlo pero aquí lo vamos a poner
como b
el arco tangente de la tangente de teta
es igual al arco tangente de cuatro
tercios y por supuesto el contingente de
la tangente de teta que es lo mismo que
la tangente inversa de la tangente de
teta es simplemente teta y esto es igual
al arco tangente de cuatro tercios otra
manera de escribir a arco tangente y es
exactamente lo mismo sería la tangente
inversa que se escribe con un exponente
a la menos uno pero a veces es un poco
confusa esta anotación porque no queda
claro si es la inversa o hay que
elevarlo a una potencia negativa o si de
veras será negativa bueno esa es otra
forma de escribirlo pero finalmente lo
que tenemos que resolver es la tangente
de cuatro tercios y bueno lo más
probable es que no te acuerdes de su
valor ni yo me acuerdo pero para estos
casos siempre recurro a mi calculadora
y ésta voy a acomodarme y busco la tecla
para inversa y luego pongo la tangente
de 4 entre 3 mi calculadora debe de
estar en grados y obtengo 54 punto 13
grados
así que teta es igual a 53.13 grados y
ya estamos ya sabemos cómo identificar
este punto en el plano bidimensional por
sus coordenadas x igual a 3 de igual a 4
y ahora también podemos describirlo como
r es igual a 5 y theta igual a 53 grados
y mejor lo escribo en coordenadas
polares este punto es 5,53 punto 13
grados y lo podemos ver como partiendo
del origen giro 53.13 grados en contra
de las manecillas del reloj y me
desplazo 5 unidades y eso es todo lo que
me dicen las coordenadas polares vamos a
hacer otro ejercicio y tratemos de
encontrar algo más general
siempre que lo sepamos en lo general
podremos resolverlo en lo particular
ahora voy a poner un punto arbitrario en
donde sea no como en el caso anterior y
que este sea el punto x coma y este es
el punto esta es su coordenada x y esta
es su coordenada y como convierto esto
nr coma teta en sus coordenadas polares
r comate está así que hagamos como en el
anterior ponemos aquí a r este es teta y
utilizando el teorema de pitágoras
tenemos que este que está aquí es x a
este que está acá es exactamente y acá
está x y el teorema de pitágoras me dice
que x cuadrada massieu cuadrada
es igual a ere cuadrada y tenemos que la
tangente de teta
la tangente de este ángulo la tangente
de teta utilizamos soca toa toa que es
el opuesto sobre el adyacente es de
entre equis y eso es todo lo que
necesitamos pero claro si tu quieres ir
más allá y anotarlo en tu cuaderno
vámonos para el otro lado como puede
expresar allí sí tengo r y theta como
puede expresar allí sí tengo r y theta
como puede encontrar allí es decir como
están relacionadas r iii y iv cuál es su
relación con theta r es la hipotenusa y
es el lado opuesto vamos a escribirlo
sólo que tohá
que relaciona al opuesto y la hipotenusa
si al opuesto de la hipotenusa pues el
seno el seno de teta es igual al opuesto
este lado opuesto que es y
así que es sí
sobre la hipotenusa que s r aquí ponemos
ere y si multiplicó ambos lados por r
obtengo r seno de teta es igual a g
y ahora hagamos lo para el otro lado y
entonces qué es lo que relaciona a x si
el adyacente con r
pues tengo el coche no acá
el coseno de teta es igual al adyacente
que es x si aquí va x dividido entre r
que es la hipotenusa multiplicamos ambos
lados por r y obtenemos x igual a r
coseno de teta y una vez que estamos
equipados con estas fórmulas que las
obtuvimos de las identidades
trigonométricas de soca tohá ésta
también salió de shock a tohá y
observemos estas tres ecuaciones que
tenemos aquí sí tengo estas dos puedo
deducir la tercera y lo que está acá
arriba pues es el teorema de pitágoras y
con estas herramientas estás totalmente
equipado para convertir coordenadas
rectangulares a polares y eso haremos en
el próximo vídeo